hey folks it's Vera
or is it
[Music]
yeah yeah yes it is it's it's me so
here's a video I didn't plan on doing so
last week uh I put out a video talking
about some updated uh guidelines I had
managed to get from sag-aftra that spoke
to my specific situation and the kind of
content that I make to find out uh in
specific whether or not review uh
content was allowed now they did say
that I as I said it did a whole video on
it but in addition to that they also
brought up that analytical
um content would also be fine really
they just want me to avoid anything that
comes across more as promotion or as we
might call it around here hype trailer
reactions uh unboxing of the new Sonic
Screwdriver for Doctor Who talking about
uh casting announcements or you know
leak details a plot that have come out
Etc it said like all that's off the
table but review was fine and Analysis
is fine I went on a
mild tangent in that video uh over the
fact that
while I do understand
that a good chunk of what I do is
analysis
uh I didn't say I wasn't going to resume
doing an analytical content
but I did say give me a little while to
get my feet under me on that because
I I tend to undervalue my work a little
bit uh in that particular area
and uh more than a few people
in the comments on that brought up the
notion that I had some form of imposter
syndrome
and uh
yeah I I've got some unpacking uh to do
on that
if you're not familiar with the concept
broadly speaking imposter syndrome is
something that is suffered by well
people in uh in all areas but it's
pretty common in uh creative and
artistic worlds where people
feel that they uh are not worthy of the
level of success that they have attained
a release that's the most common way
that it tends to manifest and be talked
about and that's kind of the thing
I kind of assumed I didn't have imposter
syndrome
because of the way it's usually talked
about because here's something like you
need to realize
I can be
pretty particular about definitions it's
part of why
um I like to get really granular when it
is specific but I also have a fondness
of broad terms I like umbrella terms
they have wiggle room I mean part of the
reason it took me so long to come to an
understanding of myself as a trans
person was because my understanding of
trans very specifically required
dysphoria being friends is not require
dysphoria if you are going to argue with
me on that here's a video on another
Channel I did talking about why someone
without trans without dysphoria would
still want to transition so give me all
kinds of other things to watch today but
let me tell you another story to kind of
set this
it took me
an almost frighteningly long time to
realize the effect of peer pressure on
me in my youth not because like I was
never told be cautious of peer pressure
you know don't submit to peer pressure
like we had those we had those kind of
PSA style stuff you know in grade school
when I was growing up the thing was I
didn't think I was subject to peer
pressure because nobody had ever told me
any equivalent and it's not like any of
the exact words but nobody had ever told
me any equivalent of
oh go ahead and do it don't you want to
be cool
and I know that seems weird and pedantic
and nitpicky but the thing is every time
that they would portray
peer pressure in these specials or these
talks or whatever that's the way it
always got presented and I get why I'm
not necessarily criticizing that because
they had to kind of oversimplify and
ramp it up to make it clear because peer
pressure is a very weird and nebulous
thing that also affects kids who are
probably too young to understand what it
is it's not a thing that happens to you
it is a sense that you have around you
the presence of your peers and the
pressure to live up to them but it's not
somebody literally daring you to do
something if you want to be cool but
because that was how they always
presented it when they talked about
these things to me as a kid I thought I
wasn't under peer pressure
yeah I know better now I figure that out
eventually
but because the way it was talked about
didn't match my experience
I assumed it didn't apply
kind of similarly with being trans
and now
imposter syndrome okay here's the thing
as I mentioned already the way imposter
syndrome is generally discussed it's and
it's a way I've heard you know people
who I was going to say I know not well
no some people I know but also like
creators I admire who like have said in
interviews or on podcasts or you know or
their own work or whatever have talked
about feeling like frauds feeling like
they didn't earn the success they have
feeling like they are not in fact
talented and they've somehow tricked
people into thinking that they are
talented
and there's this General background of
anxiety of being found out being
discovered as a fraud
and I don't have that
for all the other stuff going on on here
ah I do have an ego
I think I've earned the success that I
have
I think I honestly probably deserve a
little more success than I have had
I don't think I'm a fraud
I don't think my work doesn't have value
I don't think that people are
necessarily describing more value to it
than it has
but what does happen
is I am incredibly reluctant
to view myself or allow others to view
me
within the same breath and in the
echelon of people whose work I think is
way above me
where even though we kind of do the same
thing I don't want to call it the same
thing
because I think they are so much better
than I am I have no business saying that
what I do is the same as that and it's
not that what I think it's not that I
think that what I do has no value
it's just that okay if I look at
something that Abigail Thorne does or
folding ideas does or nerdsync does or
Jessie gender does
and I think okay if that's analysis if
that's video essay
then what I do isn't that
because good grief
so far beyond what I do more time more
work more effort better presentation
better delivery usually better argued
always longer I mean I just look at the
fact that
I don't script very heavily
sometimes I script completely a video
start to finish that's not common for me
though I generally only do it when it's
something where I have a lot of very
specific facts I need to be certain to
get right or I'm dealing with a lot of
numbers every now and then it's because
I need to very carefully structure
something to get to a point but honestly
a lot of times I'm working off bullet
points
I'm I have a notion of what I want to do
but I don't script a lot of this so just
on that basis alone I'm like well they
script I don't how can what I do be the
same thing
now that's not to say that I think I'm
like a reaction Channel just flying off
the coffin and fixing in the edit I do
come in here with a point I have a
specific thing to say and I have a point
to make and I have notes but like
if what those kinds of people do as
analysis then no I don't do analysis
geez so if I don't do analysis then
obviously I shouldn't be doing any of
that stuff because that's analysis and
I'm not
that is ultimately a form of imposter
syndrome
because even though what I do
categorically
is in the same vein as what those
creators and many others that I haven't
named also do
I just think their work is so much
better than mine and I do very sincerely
believe that
that it makes me not want to
claim
the same label as would describe their
work
oddly enough there was another similar
thing that happened with my transition I
have been reluctant for a very long time
to describe myself as having dysphoria I
actually did an entire video you know
multiple videos talking about
transitioning without severe dysphoria
the thing is
while I don't have severe dysphoria
nowhere near what I think the majority
of trans people have
I do have some
I have a little again I did a video
talking about the first time it kind of
Hit me hard
but
I'm always very hesitant it's called
dysphoria
for effectively the same reason
because I have friends who I've seen
what the impact of dysphoria is I've
seen how much that affects and hits them
and I look at to whatever extent I feel
it and it's
so mild by comparison that I don't want
to call it the same thing that they're
going through
I don't think I deserve to have it be
called that because I see what they go
through
and I know what I go through and it's
not nothing but it's not that
so I don't want to call it the same
thing
I think uh some people also you know
tried to diagnose lack of self-esteem oh
I've got self-esteem
if I said like I'm not devoid of ego uh
by any means but I do self-deprecate
probably more than I should
self-deprecation
like it has its place
but I think ultimately it's
a harmful defense mechanism in a lot of
cases
I think of the fact that
towards the end of this video or
actually you know what we'll do it right
now when I plug the patreon and the
little card appears up there there's uh
some secondary text that you have to
assign to that so that if people sort of
um go to that there's like a little
description that pulls up
what it currently says is uh support my
work and before that it said support my
content but before that and for a long
time it said support my nonsense
because that felt more comfortable to
describe what I do
nonsense
I still thought good nonsense fun
nonsense entertaining nonsense
enlightening nonsense at times but still
nonsense
I have this bizarre mix
of enough of an ego
to feel like I should have more success
than I do
but at the same time to believe
not that I'm Unworthy of the success
that I have but I'm unworthy to be
compared
to my uh peers on this platform
and yeah that is ultimately a form of
imposter syndrome
I didn't want to call it that because
it didn't fit my my understanding I
didn't feel like a fraud
I didn't feel like I was fooling it I
didn't feel like I was getting one over
on you
I just thought
what I do is not nearly as important or
valuable or detailed or well done or
well researched or well executed as a
whole bunch of people that I watch
yeah
this is something I gotta work on
and try to get over
and
one of the things I'm going to do to try
and do that
is dive right back into analysis videos
starting
I can't believe I'm gonna do this I'm
going to announce right now
that Saturday's video
this Saturday's video
is going to be an analysis
of Barbie and I know it's not as timely
as it was
but I have thoughts
and I'm gonna go into them and I'm going
to kind of pull the movie apart a little
bit and spread it out and look at the
components and
really talk about the inner workings of
the thing
and I'm gonna do it
because that is analysis
and that is cleared
by sagaftra
that work
which I will do and have done and will
continue to do
is analysis
it will be a video essay
will it be on the scale into the
standard set by other people whose work
I admire and some of whom I even know uh
no
but that doesn't make it not analysis
and it's no reason to not do it
so come back on Saturday
and um
see what I have to say about Barbie
just Barbie not Barbie I haven't seen
Oppenheimer I actually kind of don't
want to I haven't seen a Nolan movie in
a while
I just kind of stopped and I don't
really miss them
that's another topic though not gonna
get into that right now in any case
thank you for
listening to this
shared therapy session I guess
public therapy that's a healthy response
ah
but um
thank you if you're still watching
seriously thank you
whatever your thoughts are in any of
this drop them down in the comments
let's talk about it don't diagnose me
with anything else though uh just
please don't like if you want if you
want to say that you relate to it
because you also have this or you know
someone that's like fine but don't don't
diagnose me but with anything else
please
just like out of politeness if nothing
else
but um
you know there's the other stuff like
share subscribe I can't imagine this is
going to be pushed to too many people
who aren't my subscribers but I don't I
don't know the algorithm's been weird
lately I don't I don't know what it's
doing
I don't think I want to know
but in any case
what I want you to remember
is that you're beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
a special thanks to my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Zubin
look fuller hurray the thing that goes
to Oink in the anime Ruth Oliver B
solitary pictures old Greg Bogdan
Melinda Walters Jen Auntie Kate 808
Becky Sparks and Abby likes the poodle
Robin Powell Tracy scrabot angry Casper
Adam RDL Taylor Dave Hall and Rosalind
Bell you'll see a bunch of other names
down there as well there's plenty of
things to get on the patreon and yeah
you can hear me attempt to say your name
without embarrassing myself check out
the rewards and thank you for everyone
who supports this
[Music]
foreign